Facebook is taking on Israelis cyber
surveillance rather firm to court next
week for allegedly hacking users of its
encrypted messaging service whatsapp the
social media giant accused NSO group of
hacking into the phones of nearly 1,400
users back in October
among them were human rights activists
political dissidents and journalists and
air--so group disputed those allegations
promising to fight them vigorously
Amazon chief executive Jeff Bezos has
previously said NSO could have provided
the software that Saudi Arabia used to
hack his phone there are several
instances where NSO has been caught out
the FBI is reportedly investigating the
firm of the way its software has been
linked to hacks and to dissidents
particularly cases in Saudi Arabia in
2018 researchers in Canada identified 36
operators that they said we're using NSO
technology on targets in 45 countries
including on Omar Abdul Aziz the Saudi
critic under lizzi's later alleged in a
lawsuit the same software was used to
target dissident Jamaal keshavjee who
was murdered by Saudi agents in 2018
let's peek now - mother Nursery who's in
London he is an international law
professor at City University London has
also been advising the plaintiffs in a
case against NSO group in Israel thank
you so much for your time mr. Masry the
NSA says its technology is used by
governments to target criminals do you
buy that well in many instances we've
seen that their technology was used to
target reporters journalists human
rights lawyers activists and opposition
figures like Omar Abdul Aziz who are
working in using peaceful methods so the
the saying that it exclusively targets
criminals and terrorists it has been
proven to be false you're advising as we
said plaintiffs in a case in Israel
it seems that NSO group is facing
litigation on quite a few different
fronts yes so there are a number of
cases that are happening at the stage so
there are two cases in Israel
against and it's so affiliate in Cyprus
and there's also the case in in
California by whatsapp against MSO
because they used whatsapp and what's up
infrastructure to attack or to surveil
people and to infect their phones I'm
interested because these cases that
we're talking about have been going on
for a few years the allegations were you
know referred to a few years ago or
going back a few years is the law able
to keep up with this kind of cyber
surveillance technology well generally
speaking the when it comes to technology
technology develops much faster than the
law and we can see this in all areas of
technology and especially when we it
comes to human rights implications of
technology but what the law provides us
is a set of principles that could be
used in order to hold companies such as
NS arrow and other spyware companies to
account for the technology that they
produce how prevalent is NSO group and
this technology I mean listing off those
countries it seems like there are a lot
of governments using this software well
we're talking about industry of about 12
billion dollars a year and it's not just
NSO there are also other companies but
for NSO technology seems to be one of
their most developed technologies and
they have a and looks like they have a
long list of clients and these clients
do not particularly hold human rights in
high regards so we can see them
targeting journalists and human rights
activists rather than just focusing on
or limiting the use of this technology
to criminals and terrorists what's
interesting here now is that companies
such as whatsapp and Facebook decided to
put an end to the exploitation of their
platforms and the technology that they
use by NSA and decided to take
or to court to end this exploitation
which is something which is a good step
forward because that makes it harder for
companies such as NSO to actually use
this technology and to also target
individuals who have nothing to do with
crime or terrorism thank you for that
that's Mazen mastery they're an
international law professor